oh
eh bien bon soir divona l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs avec et
loire où l'enjeu bonsoir et loi bonsoir
stéphane bonsoir à tous donc tout de
suite on va venir à l'événement de la
semaine avec un très joli très joli
festival à bienne où ils l'événement de
la semaine c'est le tournoi de bienne
c'est vraiment l'événement du moment qui
se déroule donc en suisse dans la ville
de bienne et on va voir tout de suite
résultats classements tout ce qu'on a
envie de voir les plus belles parties et
des interviews donc première rubrique
l'événement de la semaine
voilà donc la semaine donc l'événement
c'est évidemment le festival de bienne
alors festival de bienne et loi on peut
en parler déjà un petit peu c'est un
tournoi on peut dire un peu derrière
linares où les kanji où les grands
tournois cons et qu'on a vu dortmund
aussi qu'on a vu un petit peu gêné mais
c'est quand même un tournoi de grande
catégorie mondiale entre le site et des
derniers 10 15 meilleurs tournois du
monde car oui alors pour comparer au
tennis ce qu'on a effectivement envie de
faire pour vulgariser tout ça ce n'est
pas un tournoi du grand chelem c'est un
tournoi du super 9 c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il ya eu une dizaine
dans l'année qui sont équivalents puis
ciel quand même un plateau très très
prestigieux avec notamment le jeune
ponomariov un porno mario évidemment
c'est la vedette on peut dire cette
année un budget médiatique avec on peut
citer aussi
vide l'air parce que wie der est un des
rares joueurs au monde à avoir battu
kasparov il ya de ça deux ou trois ans
au tournoi de tilburg nl a précisé
lui-même donc on sera plus plus étonnant
du tournoi c'est l inera sutil bon donc
vie des arcs et quand même donc connu
pour sa victoire contre kasparov
évidemment parce qu'il n'ya pas beaucoup
est aussi différente je pense qu'on peut
dire c'est que trois joueurs en vedette
de ce tourment oui alors boris gelfand
rappelons quand même qu'il a été numéro
trois mondial qu'il était juste en
concurrence avec yvan de chou qu'on
savait pas lequel des deux allait battre
kasparov en tout cas ils étaient 2 va
être très très prometteur et qui vont de
choc ya de cela je dirais une dizaine
d'années maintenant on bosse galles
fondent et un peu moins fort qu'avant il
est un peu au creux de la vague mais
effectivement c'est toujours un joueur
extrêmement fort capable de n'importe
quoi il est capable du meilleur et du
pire
c'est un joueur dont qui calcule très
bien et qui peut faire un peu ce qu'il
veut alors aussi on retrouve en délit
qu'on avait vu au tournoi de descamps
dit justement on avait fait une
interview de vangjeli donc c'est le
deuxième 3 deuxième joueur hollandais je
crois 3e 2 32e le deuxième 200 euros
demandée il ya trois joueurs en lan de
cette image vendredi epic est vendredi
étant le plus stable puisqu'il est
toujours en seconde position pickett et
imane sont un petit peu en train de
changer de switcher puisqu'un coup celle
inquiet premier l'autre qui est
troisième l'autre fois c'est le
contraire mais en tout cas avant de
vesly c'est un joueur très stable qui a
énormément progressé et qui a fait des
très belles performances aux
championnats du monde juniors et cadets
et enfin donc deux joueurs de très bon
niveau aussi qu'il s'agit 2009 et de
gala guerre qui sont tous les deux
suisses des origines diverses de prendre
du mieux il y passe alors en mode off
mais là je pense qu'ils les russes ou
azerbaïdjan - ex urss bien entendu jeu
voire très très fort j'avais joué contre
2009 aux championnats du monde des moins
de
vingt ans à buenos aires au brésil
buenos aires en argentine même
éventuellement louis
fini par perdre une partie assez tendue
dans ce championnat et me love avait
bien figurer mais n'avait pas gagné le
tournoi finalement en tout cas c'est un
très très bon joueur qui tourne autour
de 2500 650 mais qui n'est pas toujours
très actif certes il ne joue pas
beaucoup de partis et d'ong à la guerre
aussi qui suis donc allée 2514 c'est le
moins fort hulot du tournoi - forano du
tournoi il a écrit beaucoup de livres
beaucoup beaucoup de bouquins c'est donc
un peu consacrée je dirais à la
littérature échiquéenne est il écrit
énormément de choses sur les ouvertures
il a un peu délaissé son style de joueur
en tant que joueur mais ici il revient
en tout cas on va le voir tout à l'heure
ce n'est pas son meilleur tournoi c'est
pas son meilleur tournoi mais voilà donc
un très joli tournant avec donc ces six
joueurs ça c'est le tournoi phare on
peut dire que c'est le père près
derrière il ya le festival avec aussi un
très fort open puisqu'on retrouve aussi
de très fort joueur qu'on a vu c'est
ballot on a vu donc de grands maîtres de
très bon niveau et on a surtout vu des
jeunes et on a vu voilà le jeune
radjabov notamment radjabov alors il est
tout petit effectivement je ne sais pas
quel âge ils allaient doit avoir 13 ans
il est effectivement tout petit ce
vraiment si on dirait un gamin
un gamin
c'est un gamin donc radjabov toujours
dans ce tournoi qui qui a eu un titre
chez les jeunes je crois qu'il était
champion du monde washington ou gagner
ou non le pack adepta cadets minimes que
j'eusse comme savoir faire des jeunes
toutes les régions du monde cadets
déclarant fois ci mais il avait bien
figurer là bas en tout cas c'est un
jeune très prometteur il y avait
également galkin le russe qui est
champion du monde junior en titre en est
à ne pas négliger et il y avait un
ukrainien qui s'appelle donc volou
kittin jeanne ukrainien de 14 ans qui
est un nouveau prodige qui doit tourner
autour de 2400 2450 mais qui apparemment
j'aurais mieux que son ego donc un open
très fort et puis évidemment il ya
d'autres européennes qui sont là où
verts communaux pen s'est ouvert par
définition par contre aux joueurs de
videmment de club où il ya pas mal de
monde en tout je crois qu'il ya 700
participants où il n'y a plus de 700
personnes qui passent ces terres et
détourne le week-end des tournois blitz
est en mode partie rapide détour notre
parti dont notamment ce gros gros temps
de mettre ce gros peinent donc
effectivement c'est là tout l'esprit
d'un festival d'échecs ce n'est pas
juste un tournoi c'est tout un tout un
ensemble de tournois évidemment
accessible à tout le monde puisque on
peut toujours trouver un tournoi à son
propre niveau et perd donc un tournoi
qui est fortement suivi par la presse on
a envie à beaucoup de journaux que ce
soit en langue suisse donc
romano-germanique la dgac leurs deux
langues locales et
beaucoup de journaux qui en parle de
journalistes qui se déplace et y compris
la télévision on a pu voir la télévision
locale et nationale qui s'est déplacé
pour suivre ce tournoi faut dire que
donc c'est ce festival existe maintenant
c'est une grande tradition en suisse
puisqu'il existe depuis 33 ans depuis 33
ans il a vu passer vraiment des moments
très forts avec l'organisation notamment
de trois tournois inter zones aux dons
dont deux gagnées par maurice galle
forme d'ailleurs donc qui est un peu
l'enfant du pays on va dire l'enfant
devienne qui est toujours très content
de revenir là bas il ya vraiment des
organisations de très très gros tournois
et effectivement ça a été sponsorisée
par le crédit suisse dont il y avait des
budgets considérables qui permettait d
organisation avec des pics 1500 joueurs
qui passait dans le pen on peut dire
qu'il ya de ça entre 5 et 10 ans bienne
était vraiment la capitale du jeu
d'échecs en europe ont ils alors la
capitale ça va un peu baisser parce que
le sponsor principal donc s'est retiré
mais ils ont retrouvé d'autres sponsors
et donc ça reprend de l'ampleur et de
façon c'est connu des joueurs d'échecs
et comme on a pu le voir les grands
maîtres sont très heureux de revenir à
bienne et donc ça joue beaucoup
évidemment d'indécision d'un joueur
d'aller quelque part s'il connaît déjà
le lieu et que ça lui est déjà plus oui
disons que bienne est dans tous les
esprits comme étant un tournoi dans
lequel on a envie de participer
maintenant effectivement c'est à dire
que quand on leur propose ils sont ravis
de venir là maintenant il faut il faut
trouver des moyens pour pouvoir les
inviter et c'est là c'est là un peu ce
qu'ils pêchent actuellement mais en tout
cas effectivement bien à des superbes
perspectives puisque tout le monde a
confiance dans son nom voilà pour la
preuve est que même quand il nya pas
il n'y a pas d'intérêt annales comme à
l'époque il ya quand même ziegler
ponomariov défendent emile off est égal
à guerre qui joue donc super tournoi
alors au bout de cinq grandes on va peut
faire un petit bilan au bout de cinq
rondes en asie de l'est rente est
finalement qu elle fait un très bon
début avec trois points et demi ils
distancent largement le second 22 villes
d'un point oui lancer de l'air
effectivement dans ce tournoi il
cartonne on peut dire que vraiment qu'il
cartonne très très efficaces ils jouent
vite ils calculent très très vite il est
très très actif il a fait une super
partie contre ponomariov qui s'est
terminée par la nulle effectivement il
ya la partie du jour on va commenter qui
est la partie ce fut clair contre galles
fonde qui est vraiment un festival alors
là le festival au festival puisque ça
festival de feux d'artifice mais
d'autres sacrifices qui est totalement
délirant et démentielles c'est ce qu'on
verra tout à l'heure donc si de l'air en
ce moment sur un nuage je crois qu'il a
donc oui c'est ça trois points mis sur
cinq est il survole le tournoi alors on
a continué à parler du tournoi mais
avant
avant de revenir à ce moment est de
continuer de parler de sept satellites
aspects historiques de ce tournoi on va
voir tout de suite un clip le public
pour moi voilà qu'on a filmé la vad e
minute
on
oh
m
et voilà donc en dernier on a vient de
voir pour nos mario fin train d'analyser
contre villers on a vu beaucoup de
joueurs lors le jeune qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure c'était radjabov c'était
radjabov alors effectivement à ne pas
confondre iphone au marriott radjabov
c'est celui qui était habillé en tenue
jeunes voilà et qui est surtout brin
alors que pour ne m'a rien fait blond
voilà tout à fait une autre une autre
différence notable donc on a vu quelques
jours de la panne on a vu notamment
boris à bourthes qui a fait nul avec
kasparov dans un critérium israéliens
dont boris abrupte et très très fort
effectivement qu'à gagner l'open de
vivendi qui à 2650 et qui est un jeune
en pleine progression puisqu'il sort de
trois ans de service militaire c'était
quand même pas rien oui donc il est en
forme à une amphore ça joue ça
franchement physiquement ça joue un max
à revenir sur la place pie story qu'il
ya un organisateur ferme anisé donc fin
le créateur cet open qui l'a créée donc
si monsieur souris qui donc à bienne a
été l'initiateur de tournoi et donc la
organisé pendant trente ans il a laissé
la main qu'il ya bien quelques années
oui effectivement c'est l'organisateur
la légende enfin de l'encyclopédie
vivante de ce tournoi de bienne il se
rappelle de tout c'est lui qui fait il
un talent particulier pour trouver des
jeunes talents c'est à dire qu'il a
invité joël lautier en 1987 donc en 87
joël lautier devais avoir 13 ans encore
totalement inconnue puisqu'il n'avait
pas été champion du monde juniors il
n'était même pas à mettre internationale
donc il l'invité à ce moment là et après
c'est là que je vais loti à décoller ils
ont également invité etienne bacrot
alors qu'il était encore très peu connus
ils ont invité nombre de jeunes talents
vraiment laide on voit encore galkin
ponomariov ils font toujours des efforts
sur les jeunes donc c'est lui en fait
qui a ce talent pour déceler les jeunes
prodiges et effectivement c'est lui qui
a eu la volonté de remise et où festival
de gérer donc tous ces tournois c'est
une organisation énorme et il a fait ça
vraiment extrêmement bien pendant une
trentaine d'années donc on peut vraiment
lui rendre hommage monsieur on sourit
voilà et on a vu aussi donc un
journaliste qui s'est démené comme un
fou pour la partie presse donc ça c'est
important de le souligner parce que
c'est pas toujours le cas dans le
tournoi il n'y a pas toujours un service
de presse digne de ce nom pour valoriser
le tournant au niveau de la presse donc
c'est notre ami n'y que tu va présenter
notre avis olivier brace h eures donc
qui nous a effectivement très très bien
reçu puisque on a été très bien
accueillie à bienne donc lui il gère
très bien où il est journaliste de
formation donc il écrit très bien et
très beaux articles vrai passionné un
vrai passionné d'échecs et surtout un
véritable professionnel de son métier
toute la presse était au rendez vous et
donc le tournoi devienne très bonne
presse en suisse et on est heureux de
pouvoir apporter une touche
supplémentaire un peu au niveau
international
voilà on va voir maintenant la première
interview de pelletier yannick je crois
c'est ça yannick patier notre non pas
leur champion de suisse parce que je
suis le champion de suisse en titre donc
il est jeune il est très sympathique il
a beaucoup joué en france et n'oublions
pas qu'il est également français est
valable nationalité suisse française
donc si on peut l'envoyer sur yannick
pelletier
du jeu d'échec nous sommes ici avec
yannick pelletier champion de suisse en
titre bonjour yannick
alors le festival de bienne c'est la
tradition et toi tu es viennois
d'origine donc tu l'a connue depuis
qu'il est tout petit est ce que tu peux
nous en nous raconter un petit peu les
évolutions de ce tournoi et comment tu
les as ressenti depuis que tu es un
jeune joueur bah après fois que j'ai
joué à bienne si je devais avoir 10 ans
que fasse comme ça et puis c'était
extraordinaire de voir les grands
joueurs qui n'étaient pas tout près et
puis petit à petit je me suis monté on
avait choisi monter en grade et j'ai pu
jouer l'open des maîtres après quand on
voit les grands maîtres et puis voilà
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
important pour moi et aussi pour la
ville de bienne et la région maintenant
tu es maître international et tu
continues à participer alors il ya
encore un tournoi fort qui t'intéresse
ici bien sûr et bon il ya des failles
tourmalet grand maître il tourna le m
l'open est très très fort et à une
vingtaine de promettre donc c'est
vraiment très intéressant alors champion
de suisse cette année ça va changer
quelque chose pour ta carrière de joueur
d'échecs est ce que tu es professionnel
également ces deux questions en même
temps je suis professionnel est le titre
va pas changer grand chose pour moi
j'étais déjà sur pied en suisse un an 95
est bon là c'était déjà qu'il faut de
plus depuis important mais maintenant
bon j'ai gagné
match de barrage kong à la guerre dont
je suis pas vraiment au top puisque lui
probablement m'accorde prochain objectif
au niveau des évêques suisses et au
niveau des échecs internationaux vous
les échecs suisse et a pas grand chose à
dire disons c'est c'est un peu le désert
et apathique on sort et alain est
spéciale mais bon ça sur la fédération
survie quand même réussi à envoyer une
équipe potable aux olympiades donc bon
on naissait l'idée c'est de trouver les
sponsors mais c'est pas facile quand à
moi je jouais aux olympiades puis bon je
vais essayer de progresser le titre de
grand maître
mais quand même bien yannick fertillet
merci beaucoup merci
voilà yannick pelletier donc sympathique
champion suisse je crois qu'il aurait
peut-être pu jouer en france cissé avait
décidé de se faire
citer sur la liste france en tout cas
oui tout à fait alors ça c'est la
fameuse nationalité disons au niveau de
la fidh et de la fédération
internationale des échecs on n'est pas
forcément de la même nationalité que
l'on est réellement voilà je ne sais pas
si c'est suffisamment clair d'entrée il
faut choisir nationalité et chicken
alors qu'on a une nationalité je dirais
de politique donc yannick pelletier
voilà ici à bienne en train de jouer à
age de jouer cet open il a perdu une
partie contre boris à bourthes à la
première table bon alors ses
perspectives dans l'open il un peu noyés
dans la masse puisque cet open est
vraiment très fort et donc en fait
voilà quoi bonne chance yannick puisque
ça va pas forcément être facile ce temps
alors on passe maintenant on tourne en
premier avec un dogue à la guerre
alors joe leur sur internet nous sommes
ici avec joe gallagher bonjour juin donc
vous êtes le joueur suisse de ce tournoi
est donc ce tournoi de remettre avec des
très très fort joueur donc comment est
ce que vous allez vous en sortir puisque
je pense que vous ne faites pas partie
des favoris ici donc une préparation
spéciale pour le tournoi
j'avais pas le temps pour un temps une
préparation spéciale j'ai joué un
tournoi qui a fini de jouer avant je
suis pas très bien passé c'est dommage
mais je suis invité à la dernière maman
je vais déjà un tournoi avant ça va être
très difficile pour moi c'est clair
d'accord le début de tournoi vous avez
fait un demi point sur deux vous effet
nul et vous venez de perdre contre
pittsfield l'air
quel est vôtre que voulez-vous faire
pour la suite du tournoi quel est votre
objectif
auger pas vraiment un objectif j'ai pris
un chaque jour je le cas j'ai fait le
maximum chaque jour je pense et je peux
faire quatre
corps et donc vous écrivez beaucoup de
livres sur les échecs bouklif sur les
ouvertures qui sont publiés en anglais
ça vous prend beaucoup de temps vous
avez un peu délaissé la carrière de
joueur pour l'écriture
oui parce que j'ai deux enfants enfin
une femme et je veux pas voyagé et et le
temps j'étais si tu écris depuis sept
huit ans j'ai co-écrit un peu je vais
j'ai joué mes parents mais a déçu
et là c'est écrit enfin j'ai lu dans la
presse que vous allez vous remettre à
jouer en tout cas pour au moins un an a
commencé à jouer beaucoup plus
sérieusement dans les tournois
l'alternance pour améliorer mon jeu et
maintenant j'ai 36 ans tacle oui pour
une année je peux à ses
décors et bien bonne chance pour ce
tournoi et merci d'avoir répondu à cette
interview
joe gallagher qui donc pour l'instant
marqué qu'un demi point mais c'est vrai
qu'il a du mal à décoller mais c'est
d'une façon quand on voit une différence
de 100 200 points nous faut rappeler que
c'est très difficile ah oui c'est énorme
d'autant plus que joe gallagher est en
manque d'entraînement en manque de
compétition et là ils jouent contre des
superstars qui aux dents longues donc
notamment ponomariov qui est très très
motivés galfond de suie de l'air qui
sont extrêmement forts avant de rallier
aussi donc c'est très difficile
effectivement d'arrivée est tout de
suite allé dans le grand bain en train
de nager avec des avec des
professionnels pourraient formuler quand
même que ce vide l'air et je crois 14e
mondiale a gelé hier a été mieux que ça
à magna n'était mieux que ça peut être
descendu à la 14e place mais en tout cas
c'est effectivement un des russes les
plus forts existant sur cette planète
oui c'est un pilote des joueurs tout
simplement
pas uniquement russe on va passer
justement maintenant à peter zeidler on
va tout juste avant signaler que le
speaker zinder est relativement nerveux
on l'a vu sur les parties il n'arrête
pas de bouger il tient pas en place
il est assez nerveux même quand il parle
il est assez nerveux il est très très
speed 1 très speed est en tout cas il
n'est pratiquement jamais assis on a
l'impression qu'ils pensent avec les
réfléchi extrêmement vite et que ça lui
joue des tours où il est il doit pouvoir
faire des gaffes en tout cas il est on a
l'impression qu'il n'est pas
concentriques du tout celui d un sénat
qui n'est jamais assis en tout cas les
images vont voulons vous en dire plus on
est donc si on peut envoyer l'interview
de peter sidler ça vous en dira plus
des cônes l international tchèque news
ou arnaud louise peeters fidèles à hello
you doing so peter leading the
tournament have to want you have to a
tough to its but stats ya objectif est
winston en
france évoque les
nouveaux pics experience in very strong
terriblement versatile l'innovation pitt
garry kasparov two years ago in fine
comme briand sow qui est ce ok oui thank
you so much in the international s'ils
n'excluent what is the reasons for that
j'ai toujours
dit ça comme gesink for the end of the
year probably olympiades sont de type
ah
ok il toise et puteaux speed leurs fans
l'attendent avec gouttes finish line
cyr
voilà des petits problèmes de santé des
points d'enregistrement peeters l'air
donc on a vu qu'ils étaient
objectif on peut dire sur le fait qu'il
n'est plus un invité désormais le plus
grand tournoi du monde il a été invité
pendant un ou deux ans parce qu'il était
arrivé dans le top 10 est effectivement
il avoue que bon mais j'ai fait de
mauvais résultats c'est normal il faut
que je remonte au niveau des meilleurs
oui tout à fait il prend ça avec
sérénité son année 99 a été complètement
catastrophique et donc il le reconnaît
il s'en rend bien compte et il comprend
bien les organisateurs qui ne l'invitent
plus puisque effectivement on ne peut
pas non plus inviter des russes dans le
même tournoi hélas les inviter les
organisateurs des tournois du taux prend
cinq ou six plus grands tourments du
monde il est tout à fait vrai donc il a
il a joué très peu il a il a extrêmement
peu joué et là il estime cette night in
eindhoven essai il a l'impression que
son année catastrophe est passé et qui
revient en pleine forme et en tout cas
il en train de nous prouver plutôt bien
puisqu'il a fait un départ complètement
canon départ canon en est donc à ce
vilain rossi qui va probablement donc
jouer la world cup il le dit en chine
doit il avoir le coeur brisé par la fidh
et et qu'il espère pouvoir jouer le
championnat du monde s'il a lieu s'il a
lieu voilà il devait revendre
championship il y aura-t-il un
championnat du monde il ne le sais pas
en tout cas tant que les invitations
n'ont pas été envoyés le tournoi n'est
pas officiel donc pour l'instant
apparemment personne n'a reçu une
invitation pour ce championnat du monde
annoncée à téhéran et new delhi oui donc
suspense en tout cas peeters l'air
jouera s'il ya un jeu ceci dit attendre
mais aussi un tournant dans la série
télé parler d'eux
son départ il était assez content mais
il attendait la cinquième ronde pour
savoir s'ils étaient bien est justement
un cinquième en il est en tête avec une
bonne avance oui la 5e ont en fait il a
quatre points sur cinq je pense je pense
qu'on s'est trompé il a gagné trois
parties il fait deux nuls ouais donc
tout à fait remarquable départ de plus
tard c'est de l'air effectivement donc
douanes qui doit être content en fait
oui vous plutôt content plutôt contents
on va en tout cas effectivement ça fait
longtemps qu'il n'a pas joué il revient
il revient et cartonne comme un fou
puisqu'il a battu galfond dit il a battu
joe gallagher enfin il a gagné beaucoup
de partis trois parties sur cinq c'est
c'est bien considérable donc content
tranquille et serein pour la suite de
temps alors on va voir maintenant un
autre joueur qui est un peu moins
sereins puisqu'il et la russie - 2
points mais c'est un joueur très très
fort qu'elle était candidat au titre ou
monial qui a été donc troisième joueur
du monde c'est le sympathique boris
gelfand israël est maintenant
extrêmement sympathique google phone qui
a accepté de répondre à l'interview et
qui en plus nous a commenté un morceau
de partie mais ça je crois qu'on le
verra après on verra prix
du plat et stoneham intime ville de
joliette attise notre solos duos cordes
want want to have to come and roll hall
of fame
et
objective sqli twins étonnamment habile
if so i managed to do they do
in
billong time ago sohou la tradition fois
you like this place
de vote
et sans people think you can be world
champion
dans son contenu explique vi se donne
dix france
maniez
water project c'est une chaîne
généraliste ou be still walking piano
you just want to play coach est
automatique chez soi improve
gloucester provient
des
textes tellement tu voulais y sophie des
world championship hésite old
men x men étonnamment tout comme so
hockey we have the beast rôle world we
find your love is in ta bio
voilà sympathie que maurice belay la
forme on peut dire c'est un des joueurs
du circuit qui nous a le plus surpris
par sa sa sympathique où il ya quelques
joueurs comme ça on est de les avoir il
est très très expansif il nous a parlé
énormément après l'interview avant
l'interview en tout cas il est très
content de travailler s'il a des très
bons souvenirs notamment l'internet de
1993 que dire d'autre à la fin il espère
qu'il va pouvoir tenir ce enfin qu'il va
pouvoir jouer aussi bien qu on a que ce
qu'on attend pour l'instant ce n'est
malheureusement pas le cas puisqu'il
avait un point et demi sur quatre donc
il est père d'une partie contre il n en
avait pas gagné donc début de tournoi
difficile pour boris qu'elle fonde
cependant que dire d'autre toujours ce
doute sur le champion du monde phillips
il est champion du monde les joueurs ne
savent plus est en tout cas mettre tous
le doigt sur ce problème oui je crois
que c'était vraiment leurs problèmes
actuels peut-être le match gasparo
cramique va permettre de remettre les
pendules à l'heure mais ça va être
suivie du championnat du monde à new
delhi donc tu auras encore deux
champions du monde voire trois puisque
carpeaux fait et pas déchu encore parce
qu'ils encourent en gros c'est jackpot
et en france et non mais ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que l'idéal c'est que moi je
vois ici très simple chronique gagne et
se raccorde à la fille d et sa voix
grave serait ennuyé sahraouis ça résout
le problème ça résoudrait le problème
est tout à fait sérieuse oudrhiri donc
on va on va voir peut-être une pâleur
avant de voir la suite évidemment c'est
une analyse les fondements voir la
position que gulf air nous analysé alors
c'est à dire qu'en fait on va entrer
dans la deuxième partie de l'émission
moi c'est à dire les positions critiques
et les parties commentées nocture à deux
segments à voir donc sur pau lons et la
deuxième série qui est donc la partie de
la semaine qui sera divisé en deux voilà
voilà la partie de la semaine donc on va
voir tout de suite une position donc là
ça va être assez court parce que
d'opposer une fin nous a fait une
analyse succincte mais intéressante de
sa partie donc contre eux
vadim i love contre milo voilà et on va
voir tout de suite une position si on
peut mettre un petit en bas à droite je
pense qu'on est en train d'y travailler
en tout cas voilà dans leur site voila
voila donc on voit une position de la
partie contre 1000 offres qu'on peut
télécharger sur internet sur par exemple
the wicked chess notre partenaire
anglais vous avez qui ont fait
l'émission anglaise avec ma copine donc
les partis sont disponibles donc vous
pouvez télécharger les partis voir cette
partie donc entre golf hand et milosz et
on arrive donc au 33e coup à cette
position d'un e3 ou là donc bourhis nous
fait une analyse et l'envoie titre en
voilà donc des mêmes trois c'est le
dernier coup des noirs voilà ici les
blancs ont donc une position qui a l'air
qui semble avoir être prometteuse
puisque les pions blancs côté et roi
noir sont bien avancés c'est cette
fameuse chaîne de pions le fou de vadim
enough à les enfermer et ici donc dans
cette position boris qu'elle fonde fait
la faute et c'est ce qui va nous
expliquer tout de suite si on peut
envoyer son commentaire voilà
dix fois
just blaze en guinée
queen's c'est impossible to go back
france bat
controlling the squid and aliens
granby
cette
possibilité doit y autre chose vis
quincy
for
this is it
ok so
what can et c'est ok
ok few
voilà donc voilà très intéressante
analyse et on va peut-être revoir un
petit peu les idées que nous a donnée
pour ce qu'il fait dans cette position
donc nous allons nous remettre en petit
voilà en incrustation donc ici qu est ce
qu a dit boris qu'elles fondent dans
cette position ils avaient le choix
entre deux possibilités donc la
possibilité qui était de ramener la dame
en f3 qu'on va regarder et la
possibilité qu'il ait choisi qui est
donc dame c4 alors regardons d'abord la
partie ça paraît plus logique c'est ce
que nous a montrée en troisième coup ils
jouent dame c4 avec l'idée d'attaquer le
pion f7 alors l'idée effectivement de
passer à tout moment sur la case 17 qui
empêche les fils de la dame
effectivement ça contrôler la casse de 2
sets c'était la menace des noirs et des
16 dames deux échecs qui gagne la tour
oui oui tout à fait ici donc avec ce
coup d'oeil ces quatre ils menacent donc
il défend et il attaque en même temps
ils menacent tour 17 et le pion donc f7
ici sera attaqué seraient attaqués et
indéfendable simple on verra donc ici
pour skf on n'a pas vu de défense il a
donc joué dans ces quatre évadés me love
a trouvé un très beau très beau la seule
défense en fait on est en position ses
défenses et le coup c7 c6
apparemment qui n'a l'air de rien il n'a
pas vu parce que le guen fans parce que
ce puritans prise mais en fait on voit
très bien que si la dame prend le pion
les noirs jouent dames deux échecs et
ramasse la tour blanche voilà donc c'est
une possibilité ici c'est ce qu'on va
voir d'un processus il ya dames deux
échecs au roi
c'était la menace des noirs au départ le
roi bouge et on ramasse la tour qui
n'est pas défendu souvent vos pas comme
ça les petits coups qui sont pas
possible parce que la pièce est en prise
mais on oublie qu'on revient dans une
position qui était pas bonne et alors
qu'est ce que ça change maintenant c'est
6 c'est que après tour 17 donc qui est
toujours le coup critique puisque sa
menace sa menace matin c'est mon
instinct propre chef cette suite d'un
profond échec et mat oui ici la tour
vient 2 à 5 ans des 500 voilà intercepte
l'action de la dame oui et menaces
de prendre la tour 17 et si la tour va
sur bessette par exemple il ya la tour
qui viennent faire un échec et mat sur
le roi n'aura blanc oui alors ça
commencerait très critique s'il y avait
damé tour en action ça pourrait être
très chaud donc ici tout reprend souvent
ses forces et c'est la fin de la partie
qui comprend dame prend hélas il n'y a
ce qu'on appelle un échec perpétuelle
c'est joli après oui c'est assez joli
ces thématiques surtout des mots deux
échecs voilà le roi peut tenter d'aller
en acheter trois mais il est très vite
rappelé à l'ordre damages 5 l'échec on
est obligé de revenir en g2 voyez on n'a
pas le choix on n'a pas d'autres cases
en retour en ville ou voilà et là on
peut aller ni pas un chien parce qu'il
ya mat oui angers 1 et là il ya toujours
dans un échec qui remet le roi sur le
psg 2e donc c'est un échec perpétuelle
au bout de quelques échecs 5 6 échecs on
répète trois fois la même position et
donc la partie nulle c'est à dire qu'en
fait cette proposition à se rappeler
c'est la position d'amarrage et 1 dames
devaient 3g 2 et la dernière c'est
dommage saint pierrois je crois on ne
peut pas s'échapper de ces trois cases
l'a donc trois cases pour le roi blanc 3
pièces pour faire échec c'est un échec
perpétuelle donc les noirs arrivent à
s'en sortir comme ça parce qu'ils ont
perdu un pion ils ont intérêt à sauter
sur cette occasion ici boris gelfand
donc n'a pas fait nul on pas vu donc
c'est pas vu ces six mois le coup c'est
6 donc nous revenons à la position de
départ qui est celle ci est donc qui
proposait un analyse l'autre ou que
l'autre candidat damev trois dames f3
l'idée de ce coup et d'échanger les
dames et d'obtenir ce que boeing et le
fond d'appels une complète domination
oui une domination complète c'est-à-dire
qu'après d'un programme pratiquement
forcé puisque damas est n'offrent pas de
belles perspectives pour les noirs
puisque aucune pièce ne bougent pas ils
font de la préciser la tour on ne bouge
plus le fou ne bouge pas la dame ne
bouge pas un joujou dcrg tour 17 on sent
qu'on commence à s'infiltrer dans le
camp des noirs et ça devient
catastrophique donc ici il faut échanger
dame maintenant le roi prend voilà ici
on voit que la tour en a 5 peut toujours
pas trop bouger le fond et fuites non
plus donc les blancs contrôler la seule
colonne ouvertes et ils ont un plan très
simple qui est donc le roi qui vient en
quatre juridictions qui avançons g4 des
pions qui avance enlève 5 avec donc une
très très belles perspectives
normalement boris qu'elle fonda
mentionné qu'il allait prendre l'option
c est qu ici la finale était
techniquement gagnante voilà donc il va
il a raté cette vie n'a pas vu ses 6 ans
fait tout ça n'a pas vu ses six essais
en fait il a eu le choix entre les deux
coups il a vu qu'après dame f3 il était
clairement mieux et finalement ils
cherchaient c'est un léger sa note il a
vu dames c'est katy s'est dit oh bah
tiens c'est matt ouais donc je joue dame
ces quatre là me dauphin jouée ces six
là il a compris que c'était trop tard il
a raté sa chanson comme quoi ça se joue
un coup un coup qui fait la différence
entre un point où un demi point voilà
c'était voilà donc un tour très très
sympathique analyse de bouhriz la fin ne
s'est pas souvent connu les années de
joueur on se rappelle l'année dernière
l'analyse de peter lik au pire les côtes
dans sa partie contre rallyman
l'émission est encore disponible c'est
celle du 14 janvier si je me souviens
bien avoir la revoir toujours sedan
l'honneur chez les gones bien celle-là
14 janvier mais aussi de dortmund je me
rappelle celle de dortmund en juillet de
l'année dernière ou début août
l'hôpital coiffer une très belle analyse
aussi d'une de ces partis hors jeu
manquait le plus contre quel joueur mais
c'était aussi très intéressant voilà
donc on va passer maintenant à la partie
du jour parce qu'on a un peu de temps on
a vingt minutes maintenant pour voir
eloi cette partie donc entre vide l'air
et qu'elle fonde alors voilà le pauvre
bondiguel fonde qui s'est fait
proprement
explosé par peter ziegler dans cette
partie il faut bien le faut bien le dire
donc position théorique on a déjà
commenté il me semble cette ouverture ça
sera à voir dans les archives de
diagonale mais je pense qu'il s'agissait
d'une partie shirov contre judit polgar
ou shirov contre allende oui c'est une
bonne partie de l'année dernière et ce
qu il ya une partie je sais pas si elle
est pas une partie aussi pôle gare à
nantes qu'elle avait gagné oui oui exact
effectivement c'est possible je sais pas
si on allait commander ou pas mais je
vais me sam avoir vu c'est en tout cas
c'est une ouverture enfin c'est ce qu'on
va voir cesser
l'ouverture curieuse méconnu curieuse
mais très connue c'est une ccn l'âge
d'or la spécialité de brigade forment
effectivement celui-là était
complètement sur son terrain dans cette
ouverture puisque c'est de la tactique
c'est de l' attaque c'est à dire tout ce
qu'il affectionne donc on va commencer
voilà nous y voilà au
près voilà nous voilà incrusté avec un
système elliptique qui vient d'être mis
au point donc voir notre réalisateur
voilà alors allons-y nous sommes un
poster un petit et on peut commencer au
4 c 5 donc s'essayer à vienne on ne
commet plus les coûts d'ouverture dans
les gones al déjà puisqu'on n'a pas le
temps et en plus parce que c'est dans
les archives on n'a pas le temps et puis
et façon on peut connaître 21 mai
ouverture grâce à la leçon oui donc il
faut cliquer sur la leçon et on obtient
maintenant des cours d'échecs interactif
en vidéo avec le nom d ouverture avec
les idées avec même le déplacement des
pièces qui a tout pour reprendre un
joueur d'échecs du débutant jusqu'au
grand maître tout à fait voire même
mieux garry kasparov au grain regarder
la leçon enfin on ne peut pas vous en
dire plus tu reprends des quatre
cavaliers prendrait quatre cavaliers si
ce qu'avait laissé 3 à 6 à six fours
trois fous et 3.6 à cette servante
kasparov c'est la vente kasparov qui
joue avec les blancs ou noirs et qu'ils
gagnent dans les docks a écrit gagne à
tous les coups c'est dire que la cie
jouer votre lui-même il gagnerait avec
les bleu et noir et marqué deux points
market de points c'est tout à fait
qu'elle garry kasparov c'est un magicien
kg 4l coup principale l'autre
possibilité c'est le coût de 6,5 et la
troisième possibilité c'est le coup
choisi ici c'est aussi ce qui permet
donc la fameuse attaque qui reste un jeu
d'objets 4 puisque six a intercepté le
fou c'est vite la cage et quatre non
plus contrôler les blancs se vend donc à
l'attaqué alors le plan des blancs dans
cette position extrêmement simple c'est
simple on essayait de la boucherie c'est
à dire deux jours j'ai cinq dames d2 et
grand roque enfin eu droit à l'abri
ensuite on touche le pion à acheter un
bélier hqe attachante on se retrouve
avec un duo dont on casse tout avec j'ai
6 ans que s'est terminée cette norme est
développé dans mon parti comme ça
actuellement pas en rien c'est que ça
marche très bien c'est très élevé
efficace donc ici des noirs réagissent
maintenant ils prennent le taureau par
les cornes barcella qu'on avait vu de
cette partie fameuse partie de shirov on
va voir que l'idée après eux 5 sél
attaque le cavalier blanc et le problème
c'est que les noirs attaque le pion g4
fou fou ces 8es cavaliers f6 prendre le
projet qu'a donc si on veut pas perdre
le pion le seul coup mais ni risquer
c'est de jouer cavalier à f5 alors
pourquoi est ce qu'il est risqué c'est
parce que le cabinet vient au f5 donc
effectivement intercepte le fou le pion
gkp n'est plus à prendre et bien chez 6
voilà le problème cgeci c'est là le car
il a plus de casse il parle depuis
angers 4 et perdu voilà et si on perd le
pion gk plus d'attaqués plus d'attaqués
et puis surtout on a perdu un pion oui
de kid attaque en plus lyon péremption
opération d' attaque donc c'est pas
c'est pas possible on ne peut plus
reculer c'est trop tard donc ici quand
on quand on ne veut pas partir et qu'on
est attaqué il faut contre attaque il
faut contre-attaqué g5y voilà donc on
donne une pièce attaque le cabinet 6
mais en fait on peut dire les noirs
prennent matériel 5 et je prends le
khalife 6 et c'est normalement c'est ce
qu'on dit c'est ce qu'on dit énormément
c'est ce qu'on fait mais ici si on prend
le cavalier 6
c'est un choix assez logique et assez
normal je ne sais plus exactement ce
qu'on joue je crois que c'est 5 à 4 et 5
à 4 ce coup là qui chasse le fou et qui
commence donc à gagner du territoire
pour les noirs tient plus le plus réussi
c'est con damné le pion réussite va être
ramassées donc ici on ne prend pas m6 on
sacrifie une pièce c'est à dire que
quand on a dit à il faut dire b on est
ici on sacrifie donc complètement la
pièce secrète curieux c'est là où c'est
là on voit toutes les ouvertures c'est
curieux alors le cavaly effectivement
pour l'instant ne peut pas vraiment
repartir parce que s'il vient au 17 ça
quand même très très risqué puisque on
voit un embouteillage complet dans l'est
des pièces noires et puisqu'on ne
sortent plus les blancs ont tous sorti
peuvent lancer une attaque fulgurante
sur le pion à vii oui c'est grave et on
voit que ce qui est fait est très faible
et sa menace tout de suite dan des 5 par
exemple quelqu'un matin il y avait deux
cases des 5 et 4 qui sont à disposition
pour le cavalier blanc donc il ya des
très belles perspectives nées ici les
noirs n'ont pas dit leur dernier ils
rendent la pièce ressemble en mai contre
attaque il compte et y prennent le
centre et le contre contre attaque
puisque la d5 sa menace des cas de
fourchette sur cavaliers fou fourchette
sur kelly fou tout à fait donc ici on
prend la pièce quand même l'un des 4 b 4
et maintenant fous ces quatre défenses
indirectes c'est-à-dire que si on était
amené à prendre l'une des deux pièces
puisque les deux piasses en attaque et
il y aurait poussé quatre pions avec cet
échec échec et le roi sera obligée de
prendre le fou objet de prendre fougue
et de prendre une pièce de plus il est
là parce qu il a pas le choix il n'a pas
le choix il ya pays peut pas jouer autre
chose d'un peu de votre couple la dame
noire se retrouveraient emprise moi je
pense qu'on va on va vous montrer cette
vente la en images puis on prend fou
preuve cet échec au roi pamfou et là
d'un programme boum d'un programme boom
effectivement c'est le cas de le dire
ici le roi se retrouve complètement
dénudé donc au niveau matériel on a deux
pour la dame sait déjà pas suffisant en
plus le roi noir est complètement
complètement explosé donc ici ce n'est
pas une option on ne peut pas jouer
comme ça alors retour en retour nous
allons revenir rapidement ouh là là que
se passe-t-il travail par la technique
poussée 4 + segat donc les pièces ne
sont pas prises donc contre attaque
encore une fois des noirs dans cette
attaque le fou c4 donc à toutes les
caisses noires blanches entreprises ici
il s'agit d'une triple attaque c'est une
triple attaque si ce que le dôme c'est
cette attaque le fou ces gars là est le
pion des cartes continuer à attaquer et
qu'elle et ses 3 et le faut et 3 donc
quand les noms vont récupérer quelque
chose donc les blancs font une triple
défense dam des trois qui défend les
trois pièces bon malheureusement
effectivement qu'on a pu on vient
prendre une pièce on a très peur d'une
pièce mais si on prend fou
grange et la grand que moi là alors là
qu'est ce qu'on voit premier bilan
toutes les pièces blanches sont sortis
il ya plus qu à tout rachat qui dépend
jeu sinon tout le reste est à fond à
fond puisque la dame est là tout en
contrôle
donc fortement la colonne des ouais il
faut pas que la dernière bouge trop
parce que sinon il y aurait un math
voilà le fou c4 continue son travail sur
les cases blanches chinois est le cas et
c'est 3 alors lui c'est pire il est prêt
à bondir sur la case des cinq poules à
15h04 éventuellement la case aux 4 il
attaquera la dame donc ici des pièces
blanches sont à fond est à noter que les
deux branches ses deux pions et fils f5
doublé mais dans le carnet noir sont
très très embêtant est-ce qu'on peut
noter que les noirs on les empêche de
sortir leur fout de ses 8 il n'y a pas
beaucoup de cases et le fouet fuite a
pas de case très très intéressante
peut-être la case h6 oui les cas par cas
pas l'air non plus très très
effectivement les deux pions pointer
rouge ici sont des bons motifs
positionnelle oui puisqu'ils contrôlent
beaucoup de cases à proximité du roi
c'est des épines coin quand c'est des
épines cd véritable épine purpan f2
alors ça c'est un coût qui est
discutable ouais effectivement puisque
on a l'impression que ça paiera temps
mais ça me fâche c'est une tourbe linge
venir sur la case e 1 oui tout ça
contrôle des cases important part de
rien ce pion contrôler les cases de
monde et j'ai un oui est donc en fait au
lieu de dire que c'est une perte de
temps on peut dire que ça va en gagner
ces taxis des blancs sont amenés à aller
chercher ce pion pour pouvoir placer
mieux leur tour on aura gagné du temps
mais si celui-là on ne l'entend pas
comme ça voilà vie des envies des lilas
il a quelques autres choses il a calculé
autre chose il a calculé qu'il allait
donner encore une pièce oui faut prendre
cet échec pourrait avoir noté que la
première possibilité d'emprunt fou cela
ferait a demandé huit pour les blancs
échec et mat heulin donc la dame
viendrait sur la g noir prendre il fout
ça serait sanctionné tout de suite par
dame en des huit échecs et mat protégé
par la tour d un mélo renoir est pris au
piège le baiser de la mort le baiser de
la mort puisque la dalle embrasse le roi
fortement et goulûment et volume en vo
ici le roi se retrouvait complètement
étouffé voilà donc le roi est obligé de
prendre le fou le roi doit prendre le
froid prend fou f cette voie là mais par
contre les blancs dans une pièce alors
des blancs continuent d'amd 5 et chaque
au roi voilà alors c'est là pour moi le
foot 5 et bien parce que sinon ils
auraient faut aussi ce qui serait
embêtant oui le curé 5 effectivement est
très important ça limite bien l'action
du fou du foie aussi
enfin du fou celui qui ne peut pas
revenir au site et s'il ya une partie où
le roi est revenu à 8 qui donne lieu à
une position très compliqué donc on a
toujours une théorie on est toujours en
théorie c'est toujours les fameuses
parties de shirov d'inde et de pôle gare
ils sont 3 il ya galfond no 6 qui avait
déjà je le savais déjà perdu contre
alexei shirov ici donc roi prend 1,6
alors que roy 8 est une autre
possibilité position très très compliqué
évidemment mais c'est jouable 3.96
cavaliers eu quatre échecs au roi voilà
alors on ramène une pièce l attaque avec
une pièce très bien placé difficilement
délogeables ou et qui contrôle les cases
proches du roi noir alors cela dit il
faut dire quand même que les blancs on
apprend on a l'impression qu'ils perdent
un peu tous leurs pions pas puisque
europe en pion est possible alors
effectivement c'est très très chaud un
possible que ça mettra un tour les uns
je pars dans les tours blanches plus
vite parce qu'on pourra jouer tourache
en f1 par exemple menace tourcoing f2
avec échec et toutes les tours vont
massacrer d'euros en impression alors
une petite remarque sur cette position
elle est très tactique mais pourtant
l'ordinateur n'y comprend rien c'est à
dire combien cette position-là sur
frissons sur un logiciel d'un module
d'analysé
l'ordinateur dira toujours que les noirs
sont gagnants ou alors presque toujours
en fait ce n'est pas du tout le cas les
blancs une énorme initiative ils sont
deux pièces de moins mais
ici le roi noir ne peux pas respirer
dans cette position typiquement dans une
position où le matériel ne compte plus
pour preuve cinq a déjà été jouée mais
ici galfond du roi aux 7,6 des jeux f6
échec scolaire un très bon coup puisque
c'est une nouvelle épine place et on
remplace l'ancien curé fils par le
nouveau par le nouveau on est en train
de gagner du temps le roi noir par
n'apprend pas de bouger on perd un peu
de contrôle des caisses de
l'enchantement perdre le contrôle les
quatre manches 3,8
alors ici on se dit bon bah là qu'est ce
qui se passe maintenant à venir le four
et sortir le cavalier à sortir aussi il
ya des blancs semblent un peu essoufflée
voilà il faut trouver une nouvelle façon
d'augmenter les initiatives voilà et cet
échec en redonne une pièce alors on
continue non là on ne donne rien puisque
sur des champions voilà il ya le fameux
baiser de la mort j'ai parlé de la mort
d'homme des huit échecs et mat donc ici
3.27 est impossible puisque le pion à
vii est défendue par la dame - est donc
toujours eu cette recette est forcée et
maintenant c'est là que celui d'air juin
pour assez astucieux il va passer de
l'autre côté bon passer de l'autre côté
on ne voit plus les perspectives on ne
voit plus comme en attaque et comment
profiter de la demande et 5 on va donc
la transférer c'est vrai qu'on aimerait
bien la voir ici la dame voire même en
effet 6 où il donnera échec et mat donc
dam des deux ombres passe de l'autre
côté on menace d'alger 5 celui d'un math
assez rapide et assez violent oui donc
d'amener deux coups très fort dams et 6
à noter que la menace était également
des champions avec deux qui est encore
jouable ici mais en fin d'année ses six
attaques le cavalier de quatre attaques
locales du 4 défend la casaque si ça
c'est très important oui ça empêche adam
fils matt éventuel pour plus tard mais
c'est très dur a commenté cette partie
parce qu'on a l'impression que les noirs
n'ont joué que des mots venir puisqu'ils
ont toujours bouger le roi est toujours
bouger leur donne pour l'instant ils ont
sorti aucune pièce n'est pas trop le
choix ils n'ont pas trop le choix ils
ont deux pièces de plus mais pourtant je
prends le choix d'avoir deux pièces de
plus ça c'est beau c'est
comme si ces données comme si comme s'il
fallait donner ses pieds soit fait pour
gagner ce qui est un peu moins souvent
d'ailleurs comme pour une attaque de
maths décor d'un g5 échec au roi ça
continue donc ici toujours pas de choix
si le roi vient aussi ce concert ceneda
même si c'est chaque étape il n'y a pas
d'autres coûts que roy prend accepte on
reproche est complètement là encore une
fois les blancs force et noir à prendre
ça fait trois fois ou qui force et noir
à prendre du matériel alors on a donné
les deux pions et 5e si c'est vrai
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'on a donné
cette option n'était pas obligé de les
donner quand même on en tue les garder
et bien c'est pour ouvrir la colonne f
puisque maintenant c'est l'heure de
tours h et enfin la dernière pièce qui
n'était pas en jeu voilà elle n'est plus
gêné par cette option qui n'ont disparu
on n'était que ça donne une pièce est
encore une fois puisque le cac valeo 4
et 30 prises oui le cabillaud 4 est en
prison doivent s'assurer un match rapide
alors on peut on peut le détail et
d'impro cavaliers c'est une possibilité
cela psa n'a pas été jouer bien sûr
puisque après tourcoing f-22 possibilité
enfin on peut rendre le matériel on peut
donner la dame mais dans cette position
c'est pas vraiment une option sur rouen
8 il ya le fameux mat voilà ton est vite
maths et autres possibilités si le roi
décidé de venir en de 6 voilà ce serait
une dame a un fils et sa merci maxime
est donc c'est donc ici c'est un
massacre effectivement pour lequel 2 4
n'est pas une option il faut jouer autre
chose ouais donc là le nom choisi de
sortir leurs pièces et ils font bien
parce qu'il fait c'est ce qu'il faut
faire quand on est en infériorité comme
ça fout c'est 5 semble être un très bon
coup puisque ça évite tourcoing f2
bonjour fo pointe deux et ça débloque
une pièce a développé une pièce vide
l'air joue cavalier points à eux deux
dans la nuit un moment extrêmement
important de la partie
c'est à dire que si les blancs enfin si
les noirs peuvent jouer il faut prendre
cavaliers ils vont éliminer une pièce
d'attac très importante c'est ce
cavalier et donc a priori pourrait se
défendre mais là on voit pas trop on ne
peuvent pas trop parce que sur fou prend
cavalli le jouet est encore le matin je
n'ai malheureusement dit encore le match
et c'est justement pour ça que la
pollution ne voir et désespérée c'est
parce que justement ce coup-franc kelly
est impossible là c'est les même
variante suroît aux six dames m6 maths
et seront huit tours des huit matchs oui
donc c'est complètement impossible de
reprendre c'est là qu'on voit là c'est
dingue parce que les noirs c'est marrant
parce qu'on voit quand même que les
noirs toute la pièce ladies man c'est
encore sur leur case de départ selon
vous la force du développement la grande
force du développement si on fait bien
attention à bien se développer oui on
peut donner du matériel pour attaquer
l'euro d'autant plus que là on la
donnait pas dans le désert puisque on a
quand même y'a plus rien devant le
renoir le roi noir il est complètement
dénudé donc ici quelle épreuve de fou
preuve de n'est pas possible et c'est le
lard est mort pour le roi noir parce que
le cavalier va bondir en libérant la
tour il y aura toujours les deux tours
qui attaquent avec toujours cette menace
terrible et le cavalier en plus qui va
s'ajouter donc c'est terrible c'est
vraiment beaucoup trop leurs boys band
sort une pièce cavaliers 17 mai cavaillé
j'ai quatre échecs on est en train de
s'infiltrer alors on va on va peut-être
revenir sur cette position claire les
noirs ont pas le choix ils peuvent eux
sont obligés de jouer 1,8 ils sont
obligés de jouer en 8 puisque sur 3,6
suivrait entre autres je pense qu'il y
en ad'autres le mat avec tous
réussissent donc on peut le on peut
mentionner sur oasis la tour gan vian m6
et quand le cavalier prend la tour des
dames prendre les et de la mort musée de
la mort ou issu le roi bouge évidemment
prendre et la dame avec la tour en
tenant en échec de la dame ce qui permet
par la tour est donc terminé la partie
aussi donc ici roi 8 est obligatoire
mais là on sent quand même qu'il ya un
gros problème pour les noirs ça doit
mater dans tous les coins cela
permettait d'en trouver quoi le choix le
choix si l'air est très logique
c'est à dire qu'on a envie de mettre une
tour sur la colonne eux pour assassiner
complètement le roi noir donc on élimine
le défenseur on joue cavalier prendre le
5e lebron james est donc sûre qu'elle
valait prend cavaliers il y a le match
retour des 8es chaque et nantes tout
simplement le cavalier donc et chloé qui
a été sept ne peut pas bouclé donc ici
très difficile de proposer des coupes la
dame est attaquée d'un mois donc les
noirs font toujours pas sortir leur
pièce en plus leur cavale 17 bon mais il
n'empêche le pousser lui de bouger non
vraiment ils ont vraiment rien pour les
noirs là non là c'est totalement une
catastrophe lecavalier a eu cinq
attaques la dame ça va encore demander
du temps pour les noirs et les colonnes
la colonne s'est ouverte donc ici c'est
un drame damas six tours haeffelin les
blancs jouent c'est peut-être une des
premières fois où les blancs jouent avec
la même pièce oui un jour qu un coût
relativement calme par rapport au
précédent très calme mais enfin ça fait
mal quand même puisque sur le chemin de
la tour se trouve le roi noir et la dame
noire ça fait 2 2 pièces majeur à
défendre à tout prix sur cavalli prend
cavaliers il ya plus de m'attendais vite
médias simplement tout reprend cavaliers
tour un cavalier qui cloue la dame noire
qui perdu maintenant peut plus bouger
parce que c'est la dame noire bouger
échec de la tour évidemment donc c'est
interdit et la menace très forte ces
cavaliers prendre 17 attaques le roi ou
la dame au coup d'après puisqu'il faudra
bouger l'une des deux pièces qu'elle
prend 17 sacs lula da mais ça gagne tout
simplement ici boys band joue cavalier
m6 mais ici n'importe quel coût de
cavaliers gagne la partie sud l'air
choisi de mettre le cavalier en d3 donc
là on l'a dit ça cloue la dame mène avec
nous et en même temps le bonus ça tacle
ou c5 mais s'il n'y a plus de problème
il ya que deux pièces alors aux joutes
peut-être qu'à lieu 4 encore dans cette
position alors qu'il avait dit le 4 on
peut jouer effectivement mais il y
aurait simplement
alors que se passe-t-il sur 80 ans sur
vos skyrock est apte à cames dame
blanche bon par contre évidemment ce
cavalier seul cavalier n'est pas un peu
voir le voyons voyons cette possibilité
intéressante l'instant de voir un peu si
vous avez échappé c'est de cette
possibilité donc effectivement il ya
peut-être damage cinq échecs tout d'un
match 5 échecs on enlève la dame avec
échec mais voilà si la dame noire essayé
de s'interposer on prend le clavier les
clichés comprendre qu'abdiquer chèque et
on ramasse le four avec la dame avec la
dame si le roi noir bouge par exemple
trois fuites et bien ici le couple qui
avait dépensé 5 à dakhla dame
ramasse-tout ramasse récupère le
cavalier au coup d'après c'est la fin on
aura plus on a un plan de plus avec les
blancs mais menaçant qu'au retour des
8es encore toute l'attaqué il ya très
vite c'est terrible ici c'est terrible
c'est totalement terrible alors la
partie il n'a pas joué car il ya quatre
îles mais choisit un coup dans cette
position-là vide a choisi fawcett
fossett perde la dame donc celui de l'er
récupérer accueille les fruits en fait
le biais fruits tout reprend 1,6 fou
prend 1,6 tour 20 on continue quand même
donc taurin en place est très beau ça
tacle faut 6 et
il ya le fos est derrière donc tu as
beaucoup de pièces là le problème c'est
que les gens s'en sortir leurs pièces
mais les doutes au les deux tours sont
pas connectés et donc gens ont du mal à
venir à en défense c'est le roi qui les
empêche d'ailleurs
il va falloir protéger il faut aussi
mais ici effectivement là bon si le
football le cavalier f6 est perdue
puisque nous faut cette raclure et voit
la dame prend cavaliers il le fou ne
peut pas reprendre à cause de la tour
qui fait échec en cas de tours g8 on
suppose facilement que la dame va venir
aux cinq fortifiée encore toutes ces
menaces ouais donc ici il ya simplement
pas de solution et boris galfond juke a
validé cette qui perd évidemment après
tourcoing prend fois au 6 mai qui a même
pas été joué c'est la même pas été joués
il a abandonné ça s'est un peu moins
souvent qu'on le voit ce qu'on joue son
coup on abandonne après bon je sens
qu'on apprend d'après ces techniques
d'habitude on abandonne tout simplement
ouais on abandonne tout simplement je ne
sais pas ce qui s'est passé peut-être
que c'était un sign up peut-être que
brice qu'elle fonderait plus beaucoup de
temps il a joué kelly 17 s'est aperçu
tout de suite qu'ils avaient pour point
aussi s'il a des cheveux sont courts et
abandonner immédiatement mais il ne
devait plus déjà avoir beaucoup d'espoir
dans cette partie vous êtes notre salle
des gardes ans qu'il était il était en
crise de temps il a joué très vite ils
se rendaient pas trop quand de ce qui se
passait encore mais là bon il a vu que
c'était c'est totalement fini puisque le
fou c'est aussi ça être perdu le fossé
est aussi derrière et là c'est terminé
l'attaqué encore trop forte et surtout l
avantage matériel est passé du côté
blanc c'est terrible c'est un massacre
cette partie c'est complètement
complètement terrible c'est un véritable
massacre très belle partie comme de
petersfield l'air qui a tout sacrifié
tout donné et qui a fini par emporter
une une excellente victoire est ce qu'on
peut dire que celui d'air un style
proche du studio chiffres non c'est pas
tout à fait 9 ttid scheer au filet un
peu plus un peu plus fou dans la
conception je pense qu'ils préparent
mieux ses offensives il était en fait la
capacité de préparer longtemps les
attaques spyder c'est quand même plus
cash certes ils attaquent dès le début
et il continue il harcèle son adversaire
il ne lâche jamais voilà donc très beau
tournoi de vienne je crois qu'on se
régale et je crois que merci olivier dhr
de nous avoir si bien reçu merci aux
organisateurs du temps de bienne de
continuer à oeuvrer pour ce très beau
festival on espère qu'on sera là l'année
prochaine tout à fait et
donc on va se donner rendez vous
maintenant pour la rentrée en septembre
puisque là on va prendre un peu de recul
bien que c'est fini c'est pas tout à
fait fini puisqu'on va retransmettre le
championnat de france où ils prochain
grand rendez-vous à ne pas manquer ça
sera à partir du 22 donc le mardi 22
août au soir où les premiers
compte-rendus sur le championnat de
france ça sera suivi par un compte rendu
quotidien tous les soirs à 21h pour
savoir qui sera champion de france cette
année alors etienne bacrot iossif
dorfman a dit anatoli valoir aux langes
ou edward roland effectivement j'aurais
donc la double casquette de joueur est
prêt coprésentateur de diagonale donc ce
ne sera pas facile mais en tout cas je
peux être franc c'est un très beau
tournoi qui s'annonce abhisit et ça sera
bien entendu en direct sur diagonale qui
maintenant est recommandée par la
fédération française d'échecs dont la
diagonale recommandé par la fédération
pour cet échec on est très content et ça
me fait bien plaisir et et on va se
faire un encore un bon plaisir en
commentant ce championnat de france en
direct de vichy c'est une première ça
n'a jamais été fait donc la première
fois qu'une télévision
il se trouve qu'elle est sur internet va
retransmettre en direct des côtes des
rubriques quotidienne sur le championnat
de france d'échecs voilà donc que je
vous donne rendez vous mais pour le 22
août donc à vichy sinon pour la
continuité de diagonale classique entre
guillemets à la rentrée en septembre